- What's up, what's up world?
(speaking in foreign language)
- Rawgged MC bassist for Nomadic Massive,
international hip-hop band from Montreal.
("Duty" by Nomadic Massive)
♫ We rock the mic like all day, all night
(music drowns out lyrics)
♫ You know what time it is
♫ We rock the mic like
- Nomadic Massive started
out as a collective
but morphed into a live hip-hop band.
The group started officially
in 2004 in Montreal.
- [Woman] There you go.
- [Man] Ready?
(music drowns out dialogue)
One, go!
("Any Sound" by Nomadic Massive)
- I came here as a refugee
when I was a teenager.
- One of the underlying themes
is the topic of identity.
As immigrants, since
we express ourselves in
different languages than the listener,
will then identify themselves with
that little piece of Nomadic.
(lively music)
- How many languages are
in songs, in our band?
- I'd say at least five.
- Nah, I think you're wrong.
- More?
- French, Spanish.
- [Meduza] Caribbean Patois.
- [Diegal] English, Creole.
- [Diegal] Portuguese.
- Arabic.
And the Native languages, that's eight.
- Yeah, so eight.
("Any Sound" by Nomadic Massive)
- So a lot of times if one of us gets
the inspiration, and
starts a chorus in English,
then one of the MCs might
really feel his story
or his piece in French.
And some of us just
express ourselves better
in our native tongues.
That combination could not have
come together anywhere else,
the way it has come in Montreal.
(gentle music)
- Montreal is a microcosm of the world,
you see different ethnic
backgrounds, and cultural groups.
- People coming up to us and say
"Wow, this was my favorite show because
"I just felt so positive and included."
This experience of
understanding multiple languages
in one song, is very Montreal.
(gentle music)